i heard that you are a big advocate of  the rock coming back too have you called  him have you talked to him at all about  this making it happen he's earned the  right not to be pressured into that  choice i can say he's a fan of the wwe  he's the most electrifying man in sports  entertainment so as a fan do i want to  see one of the greatest performers in  all time step back in the wwe ring yeah  but in no way am i going to call him and  if i'm going to talk to him about  something it's not going to try to be to  get him back in the wwe ring he he needs  to come to that conclusion by himself  because then his performance will be the  rock he'll be the best he can be so i i  do hope he comes back as a fan and i i  hope it's wonderful and if he chooses  not to he's earned the right to choose  not to